please welcome the
one and only
judd apatow
[Applause]
[Applause]
okay we go back a really long way
like long long way
the first time i ever directed i
directed drew the first time maybe the
first scene i've ever dr i ever directed
um the larry sanders show
that was a very scary
day for me because i never even
was sure i wanted to be a director and
one day gary just walked into my office
and went you're doing the next one
and why do you think he said that what
did he see in you i just think he
thought i'd be good at it and then
he sent me uh you know into war with you
and jeffrey tambor and riptorn oh my god
who's kind of notoriously difficult
he he was
complicated the first time i shot a
scene with him uh you know he's uh you
know we're shooting the scene and i i
was just scared to say anything i just
thought i'll get six takes from rip and
say nothing i'll have enough i'm not
gonna tell him to do anything and they'd
do the first take and he looks at the
cinematographer and he goes like what
are you doing
you're shooting my ear
and the camera was like right in front
of him like it didn't even make sense
and then the guy's like i'm right here
rip and he's like i know the angles i
shoot skeet
that would that's my first day of work
all right so you get a bite of the apple
yes and
is it like
that's it you're in well i did think oh
i guess it's i can
do this so i remember when you brought
baby mod
you know when you were doing rewrites on
the wedding singer now you were
roommates with adam sandler yes yes i
was um when we were like fresh out of
college
we lived together oh there you go i mean
come on look at you
no
i was getting i i was getting my head
shots for stand-up comedy and then adam
just jumped into the shot
um well um
tell me something only a roommate would
know about sandler well um you know back
then you know we didn't really have
anything to do because we would just do
stand up at night and so all day every
day we had to kill the day and adam had
a lot of energy to be funny if you could
imagine like he didn't have an outlet
other than his like 15 minutes at night
and so he would be really funny with us
all day
and so i remember once we went to red
lobster those commercials are such porn
right i mean if that doesn't get you hot
that wet lemon squeezy
yeah like
god that creamy noodle being whirled
exactly and back then you don't even
think that anything's unhealthy right i
just had like two fettuccine alfredo's
i'd ask for a double that's so that's
how i ate at that age every night at
like one in the morning in the improv i
would eat a double fettuccine alfredo
you're you are my kind of guy
so we go to red lobster and it's just me
and adam alone eating there and then
adam would try to humiliate me in spaces
you know so if you were like in an
elevator with adam and other people he
would always like fart and go judd
like but all the time like every time
there was an elevator you're like i i
don't want to go in there with you
and so we're we're eating dinner
and and he he like farts
i thought he just ripped and it's a
terrible one
and then he's like judd we're at a fancy
restaurant
and then i'm just like i was just like
so mad i'm eating and then like 10
seconds later a little kid like a
five-year-old just goes
mommy how come i can't smell it
and then adam cracks up like the biggest
laugh ever
runs out of the restaurant
and just leaves me alone at the table
[Music]
you